what was it about nightmare alley that  said I want to do this next and what can  you tease fans of yours about the  project well what it is and that book  was given to me in 1992 by Ron Perlman  you know and before I release aw the  Tyrone Power movie and I loved the book  and my adaptation and that I've done  with Kim Morgan is not necessarily the  entire book is impossible it's a saga  but there are elements that are darker  in the book and it's the first chance I  have in my short films like I wanted to  do nor and I wanted to do it was horror  and nor and now is the first chance I  have to do a really underbelly of  society type of movie and and I think  it's you know no supernatural elements  just a straight really dark story it  will be rated or yes they all are you  know I have to ask that because you  never know yeah I gotta go